as a man i would want to know what you
did to get to 26 years of marriage you
say you have the ideal marriage very
interesting language to describe that
ideal marriage you have a daughter why
would you not
give us some game on that
because the way that we do marriage now
like people ask me all this time they
say rolo if you weren't married would
you get married now i would say
absolutely not if god forbid i found
myself a widower or whatever you know
tomorrow i would not get married in this
present state i'm not saying the
institution the idea of of marriage is a
bad idea i have all like i've all you
probably read this as well we are better
together than we are apart we are innate
evolved natural compliments to one
another it's not good for a man to be
alone but very specifically why would
you not get married today because the
way that we do it now and this is
exactly goes back to your point where
everybody goes well alimony this and
i'll lose half my stuff and and i think
by the way i think that's kind of like a
specious argument from guys who don't
want to get married hello really don't
even make enough money
to work but they also have to play child
support they also get in child support
has nothing to do with being married you
could you could have a one-night stand
mama and pay child support i understand
but when we talk about like prenups oh
the prenup saved me yeah did you have
any kids no no but if you had kids you
would still be paying a form of child
support and a form of alimony that goes
up and and again i can get into the
divorce machine there's lots of like
well you really think that much has
changed in 26 years in terms of the
legalities of things because i don't
think much has changed no they haven't
no they haven't but i would say did you
make a bad decision 26 years no not at
all but the the thing is this is that it
is the culture has changed the culture
has most definitely changed the i like
getting into like i'll tell you what my
dad said i asked my dad one time i said
i said why did you get married to my mom
my dad was like a guy a died in the wool
atheist and my mom was a born-again
christian she later became catholic and
everything and i'm like what on earth
possessed you guys to get married
together my dad said this he's like
looking at me he says it seemed like a
good idea at the time
and and you know and thank god you know
my brother and i were produced as a
result of that and i am who i am because
of my father and because of my mother as
well but the the long and the short of
it is i understand the institution i
understand why marriage exists i
understand why pre-marital progres you
know prohibitions against you know
premarital sex uh you know uh being uh
or even pre-arranged marriages for that
i understand why those exist i don't
think that they are tenable in the 20th
or 21st century at this state i
understand why they're there and i
understand the mechanics behind them
however
expecting especially in modern day
society where like um marriage rates are
at like was it 5.1 per 1000 right now
you're looking at it you're looking at a
divorce rate that's falling off a cliff
yeah because no one's getting married
right now and the age of first marriage
is getting pushed further and further
into into our early 30s um primarily
because of a post-sexual revolution
mentality with respect to monogamy yeah
as far as best practices are concerned
like if you have all these tools if you
understand you have this database and
you have all this education about
intersectional dynamics how do you use
this what do you what do you do with
that that's not my that's really not the
purview of the the red pill and i don't
know like where like there's a lot of
people who want to be red pill voices
right now a lot of them come back to my
work that's all they do and they're
looking at mine at sort of like the
source material for wherever they're
going to take it and go with it so if
you look at fresh and fit you look at
like andrew tate you look at even kevin
samuels it's all derivatives of stuff
that i have done since
really two thousand two two thousand and
this is something you disagree with
kevin samuels on though i would because
still prescribed marriage i think okay
so here's the thing
would i prescribe marriage i would if we
had some form of marriage reform okay if
there was some sort of i've had i'm i'm
i like where this is going he's saying
i'll throw this out again i always ask
this what benefit is there for a man
inside of marriage that he can't get
outside of marriage or you're not
married like you right right now it's
like you looking and trying to find some
guy or someone right now someone some
girl wasn't that guy i'm sorry about
that out there
you're trying to find someone you're
trying to find someone it's like you're
gonna especially at your your value yeah
who you are right now um you're in a
position of sexual selectivity that most
men are never going to be able to enjoy
in their lifetime so you're like okay i
want to have kids i want to find
somebody that i can settle down with
yeah um but the the the downside risks
of that and i'm not just talking about
marriage i'm also talking about the
follow-on downstream effects of of
making a bad choice right we i've you've
heard this before i'm sure every i
forget i think it was my maybe as warren
buffett who said you know the most
important decision you can make in your
life
sort of that downstream effect it it
depends it hinges on one thing
intersectional dynamics it hinges on
being able to come together and having
that knowledgeable database i'm not
against marriage i'm against marriage in
the sense that it's like denil was
coming didn't know the risks didn't know
this didn't know all the downstream
effects that could come from it because
you have this romantic ideal in your
head that oh she's the one and most guys
live in a state of sexual scarcity so
the first girl that gets off with him
suddenly she's the one you know ordained
from god to be his wife for her forever
now this is this is what final thoughts
because we have like 20 more topics so
we're not going to spend an hour on yeah
so so uh
do you think there's any selection bias
though in the way you're describing some
of these women and in terms of the
culture
i don't necessarily think it's a well
first of all i think there is a if
there's a bias it's a post-sexual
revolution bias for the last four
generations
for some women not all women i would say
that uh in
in some effects all women and some
affects some women okay so i i made this
point with jedi yesterday as like if you
were born after saying like 1960s right
now you have had gynocentric feminist
ideals
planted into your brain that you think
are just like give it like given truths
you think that they're they're
self-evident truths whereas if you were
born in a generation prior to the sexual
revolution you it would be like you're
like what are you what are you doing
right that's fair so where's the sexual
uh revolution what's the uh 1965
[Music]
so
you
you
may prescribe marriage with with some
reforms i appreciate you saying that
well i did say that monogamy was the
bedrock of westerners
absolutely how that is formalized is
really kind of particularly to the
society of the religion like sure and so
i i would take the stance that i want to
tip the scales as much in sauces favor
as i possibly can if he wants to get
we're going to get you married so yeah i
appreciate it i mean
by my side he wants to have him he wants
to have kids
so so you say so that's great so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]